[Music]
welcome to the data science hangout
if you're joining for the first time i'm
rachel it's great to meet you
if this is your first hangout today this
is an open space for the whole data
science community to
connect and chat about data science
leadership and
questions you're facing and really just
what's going on in the world of data
science
the sessions are recorded and shared to
youtube as well
as the our studio data science hangout
site
so you can always go back and re-watch
them and
find helpful resources
we do also have a linkedin group too for
the hangout so
if you ever want to continue a certain
discussion or meet people there or see a
brief summary of a topic you brought up
each week you can do so
someone from the team can share that in
the chat now
otherwise i'll share it in just a moment
but i i do want to just say um i can't
believe it's almost july and wanted to
let everyone know that we will be taking
a bit of a break from the hangouts in
july just in july only
as we prepare for the rstudio conference
and some big announcements
but we'll be back
on thursday august 4th as well
i realized i hadn't been mentioning that
to people so just want to let everybody
know
anyways we
are excited to see you all here and
always want to create spaces where
everybody can participate
so as you know the hangouts are all
audience-led so there's three ways that
you can ask questions today
you can jump in by raising your hand on
zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and just put a little star next to your
question if you want me to read it out
loud instead or else i could just call
on you to jump in
and then lastly we also have a slider
link where you can ask questions
anonymously too and our team will share
that in the chat in just a second here
love to reiter reiterate here we love to
hear from everyone no matter your level
of experience or area of work or
industry
but with all that welcome i'm excited to
be joined by my co-host for today
alec campanini and alec you have a very
long title here so hopefully i don't
mess it up but senior manager
omni merch ops innovation assortment and
space analytics at walmart so you're
definitely going to have to describe
that
for us too
but alec i'd love to kick it off with
having you introduce your introduce
yourself and share a little bit about
the work that you do
okay hey everybody i'm alex campanini um
like you said i'm working with walmart
i've been at the store side of walmart
for like three years back when i was in
college uh went off did some mastering
stuff and then now i'm back at walmart
for the past i think two and a half
years now
i'm working inside the merchandising
area specifically
looking at optimizing our assortment
making really large bulk changes and
strategy for our assortment
this tends to happen uh it's omnichannel
so every single channel you can think of
even drone delivery right now uh we've
started trying to figure out how we
could place assortment in certain areas
what all's available what's going to
make the most money et cetera
um as well as like this digs into like
supplier so supply chain comes into it
but most of it is like it's strategy
based around innovation merch products
we build a lot of products for 3 500
merchants
in order to get those bulk changes made
as well as reviewed and so we have a
really big kind of like feedback
community for the type of work that i do
so
great thank you
um and i'd love to kick off with this
question here um but what's something
that you're most excited about in data
science in the year ahead
um
i've really enjoyed the flexibility of
things that are coming out um i mean
rstudio has done a good job of enabling
a lot of that with inside of walmart so
we actually have the the team suite so
we we utilize that to make sure that we
can actually share a lot of our stuff
across different teams
as well as have an easy you know one for
one deployment method for all of our
shiny apps um so i guess in like the the
next year what i'd really like to see
at least at walmart anyways it's just
how my mind's turning is um our slot is
flexibility around data engineering
especially as we scale and change
channels
as well as being able to actually model
that in a meaningful way
so it's for us it's gonna be flexibility
in the next year or two
so
awesome
i know i see
quite a bit on linkedin about some of
the shiny apps that you create at
walmart and
we would love to just hear a little bit
about some of those and
how they helped impact the business just
while we're waiting for some questions
to come in from everyone else too
yeah i think this will probably spur
some questions uh especially since it
has to deal with other retailers um
my main scope right now is called rest
of market
and so our what we're trying to do is
find out every item that exists in the
rest of the market no matter if it's in
the store online
through tick tock trends social
listening whatever it may be
and um it's really cool that i got it
started out as my first project because
the scope is pretty unlimited um because
you've got like walmart as its business
and then i get to take on like rest of
market as kind of its own business
um so today i own a shiny application
that is pushed to all merchandising um
we have i think a little bit over 12 000
uses on it today across all of the
merchants and merch ops
and what it does is um starting with
ecom which our first version
was insights on about 28 to 30 different
retailers in the e-commerce space you
can guess as to who those may be
with many items at the item level
a lot of different contracted data sets
that are coming in so they all come in
different grains and forms
and then the biggest thing is just to
normalize all of those to the walmart
hierarchy so we've got to have some way
to tell a merchant that something from
the rest of the market on a different
website makes sense for them to look at
so we we do a lot of data normalization
we do a lot of trend analytics for them
and then a lot of that afterwards comes
to how much can we scrape and acquire uh
to enhance our data so we have a lot of
um we have a lot of market share data a
lot of sales information um
pricing over time
um and then a lot of the best seller
trends that are popping up um so we we
do a lot of things to find out where
i guess merchants would be lacking
inside of a brand especially national
brands and then we allow a workflow to
you know quickly identify oh we're only
at 60 of this brand uh drill in what are
the top items being sold do i want
stable items do i want trending items do
i want something else that i've never
seen before or is it that i have the
item and i just need increase you know
what i'm giving to the customer do i
need to lower my price
is it shipping too slow for somebody do
we mess up the website
amazon maybe has 10 images and we have
five for whatever reason
so just it just keeps going and going
but that's my first shiny application
it's it's been a lot for about a year
and a half now
that's cool wha what's an example of
something that's like a tick-tock trend
that
influenced a brand
so so tick-tock is pretty new for us we
actually haven't engineered that fully
into the shiny app today that's that's
social listening that we're wanting to
uh to bring in
um
we're thinking about how we want to
utilize that it's it's obviously gonna
be based on hashtags that are trending
throughout wherever but we have to try
to parse out a lot of that for what is
product based versus just what else is
actually just floating out inside of
tick tock
but i think the coolest trend is
on father's day
we released a line of new golf tech
products
um and all of that actually did come
from the uh from my app so we had a lot
of the sports and fitness merchants find
out that online
we actually sell a lot more technology
rather than golf balls so these are
merchants that used to be in the store
they're setting a mod once a year we're
always going to have golf balls on the
shelf because we sell all of them all
the time it's a physical asset but they
get into the e-commerce space as a new
merchant for like omni
and then think that's the same type of
trend they find a different trend inside
of our app and then i think we they
launched a whole slew of things this
past week so that was really cool
that's great
thanks alex um libby i see you asked a
question in the chat do you want to jump
in
sure i'll even turn on my video
um yeah i was wondering if when you're
looking at the the value of a product
within a sku catalog for a brand like do
you incorporate reviews the number of
reviews the quality of reviews the
percentage rating stuff like that when
you're trying to figure out what's worth
pulling over
yeah sadly we haven't gotten into like
sentiment analysis on those reviews
we're just because of the scale of it
online
i think amazon sells like 800 million
products and so we're just looking to
acquire those in the first place much
less the reviews
um but we do bring in counts of ratings
and reviews and we try to track those
over time
so it depends on we we really scrape
like what we find in the market is the
most important so we do have sales
performance on a lot of these items for
the past four years um some of that's
acquired some of that's paid for um but
we we try to track as much as we can for
those that trend
so
awesome thank you
thanks libby harsh i see you have your
hand raised
yeah hey hello everyone actually i
wanted to ask like these days in the
walmart uh people in amazon do false
reviews also like related to the paid
reviews so how do you segregate between
the paid reviews and the
genuine reviews you are getting from the
customer like what is your strategies in
that
yeah that's the um
well that's one thing we haven't got to
like i said there's the the sentiment
analysis but that does affect our
accounts um another thing that affects
accounts just like that
is duplicate listings online
so walmart does a bad job of taking
marketplace sellers and making them put
it all underneath one item space and so
we even have duplicate listings of like
how big our assortment is uh same thing
happens on amazon same thing happens on
reviews ratings counts um and that's
that's kind of the cool part of rest of
market is that it's not even our
internal data and we have to figure out
some way to de-duplicate it
so we have different methods for doing
that internally and we have different
methods for doing that externally
a lot of it is kind of
based on different data sets we have so
if we see that one data set is an
outlier for a brand's depth for amazon
uh then we may treat the other three
that we have engineered as more of the
source of truth
but it just becomes waiting at that
point we also take it like i said a lot
of merchant feedback so if we feel like
uh there are misguided
outputs being shown to a merchant we
allow them to edit a category if we
predicted it to their space and it's
incorrect we allow them to edit like
items that we have mapped for it which
helps us understand if we're meeting
with customer needs uh almost all of
these metrics are edits one will save
and push it back
okay thank you
thank you
i think 800 million
products is really hard to imagine and
i'm curious how
do you handle all that data or what does
that look like at walmart
uh it comes down to prioritization so
the like i said there's there's really
only probably
five to ten million that we actually
care about at amazon um same thing
happens at walmart we we have
250 million i think
and the you don't even sell all of those
so we're really looking for
sales samples and and paid things within
the market uh we'll we'll actually have
uh receipt based samples come in from
different households across the market
we'll pay for that figure out what's
actually making sense we may miss some
items that way but we typically know
what's in the head and the torso pretty
well
it doesn't tell us like total market
value of an item and that's where we
start doing rest of market estimates at
the item level
we'll predict what the market demand is
and then we're working on predicting
what the walmart demand is even if you
know it's not always the same not the
same customer base so
i see a few people ask the question on
slido anonymously and one was has
walmart's relatively new subscription
service impacted your work
yes so uh we actually break out sales
samples for first party and third-party
subscription and non-subscription sales
and so this this helps mainly inside of
the pets area
obviously there's a lot of a lot of
different models that you can offer for
renewable things for life so that it
makes sense
um but yeah there's we're trying to
identify uh trending subscriptions
downtrending subscriptions um most paid
for most stable over time anything you
think of about subscriptions so
another thing that plays into that just
to piggyback off of it is services
um so amazon offers a lot of
installation services and stuff right
whenever you buy a product walmart has a
few of those but we're also trying to
match and compete on services
that's interesting um seth i see you put
a question in the chat do you want to
jump in
yeah sure hello everybody long time no
see um alec thanks for uh for taking the
time so uh you mentioned kind of like
these dual listings and things like that
and i'm sure all of us have experienced
this thing where especially when you're
trying to do analysis on like products
or whatever there's a lot of
coordination that is required
from like let's say the front front end
development or back end development that
makes maybe the data ingestion and data
analysis much easier and i'm wondering
if communication on like hey like maybe
if we didn't orient these things to be
two items that would make our lives a
little bit easier and kind of improve
our analytical capabilities does that
kind of communication exists
yeah it's starting it's starting up a
little bit more nowadays
we have good documentation on the
approaches that we've tried um with
deduplication um so the issue with
walmart is always scale and the
different types of businesses within
that scale
like on the store side you wish
everything would operate sort of the
same like if you're
if you're ace hardware
you know you've got hardware but we've
got hardware and pets and everything all
inside the same place
and so typically for um you know some
type of flexible approach deciles are
typically good or percentiles um scrape
everything out from the bottom one
percentile and that's typically your
outliers uh but to actually
i think move that throughout the
organization you know we're doing this
for ourselves right now assortment
my now strategy that this has been used
so much and there's the business impact
already there is we push our data sets
up
um we're wanting to actually get rest of
market items duplicated into our catalog
like our catalog and so even if we have
uh unmanaged records that aren't fully
complete like we don't have a unique
identifier for it or we're still missing
size or dimensions um we'll have a
record there but it'll be a much quicker
setup the next time the item actually
comes up for the merchant to put in
outer space
um that'll that should help with some
deduplication there's still a lot of
data science and guessing that goes on
behind the scenes but uh we're trying to
make sure that it gets standardized for
everybody
cool thanks planet
i see someone else had asked on slido
going back to when you're talking about
tracking prices how do you actually
track prices on amazon or from other
competitors
yeah there's there's a lot of different
ways um there's batch loads that we'll
get monthly like i said from different
data contracts um so we can actually see
the receipt based price so the thing
that somebody actually paid for at that
time
you won't know daily that's a price over
the month and so we do have to take
stats from it either
normally median just in case pricing
goes wonky on something
so we get some type of batch load it's a
little bit lagged but we also do a lot
of the um you know amazon posts that are
best sellers
um we best post our best sellers uh you
really just want to focus in on like
what the top items are trending on their
page at that time
and they refresh it so i mean we
we refresh hours i think two to three
times a day they do theirs three to four
times a day i believe and you can
consistently if it's still on that same
list check pricing as it goes throughout
the day
um one issue is zip code related pricing
um so if you go to amazon i can go check
it now
one of you all can go check it we see
different pricing for shipping or
whatever it may be different ship speed
and that's a whole different ball game
that we still have to get into
how could we
uh get all this data
not even just a scale of 800 million but
800 million by zip code in region
um and that's that's something that i
actually haven't even dug into yet so
that's cool when you say like the
receipt scans is that sometimes like
those apps that give you like money back
for scanning your receipt or
it's always cool actually
yeah i actually don't know the whole
process for now i don't i don't think
our vendors are going to let us know the
the complete story behind it
um but in essence all i really know is
that there's millions of households it's
not really just like people based it's a
household based
and they they would pay them x amount of
money to do this service for them for a
certain amount of time so they'll sign a
contract to be part of the household
review
um
i think for a year two years whatever it
may be
and that's just so that we keep it a
steady sample customer shoppers and
insights kind of stay stay relatively
the same it's spread out everywhere we
where we want inside the region and then
we just kind of aggregate and predict
from there
cool thank you
um libby i see you had another question
in the chat i'm gonna jump in
sure yeah it looks like brittany and i
have a similar question um
when you are looking at all market stuff
i feel like that's a really big struggle
you have to use external data and
it's something that everybody who has a
product or service in a market deals
with so is there a vetting process that
you go through to like vet external data
do you get a sample of it and get to use
it and then decide whether or not you
want to purchase it do you validate
reliability of the data stuff like that
so luckily enough we actually have
another team that takes on a lot of our
data acquisition as a service um so
they'll y'all heard of nielsen
you've heard of probably 1010 or npd or
all these main data contractors
some of those are are really easy and
reliable
like nielsen's kind of vetted throughout
the market already
but once it gets into smaller players we
actually do have a team that goes out
since we already have three to four data
sources already standardized into the
walmart hierarchy we can kind of guess
numbers you get a new one you check it
up against those numbers hey something
was wonky go back and forth between who
the vendor is see what the differences
are
maybe their assumptions make sense and
there's a reason why something doesn't
make like line up perfectly
um after that we just kind of use it um
you just have to see with a merchant
if there's any issues for their area are
they missing data does it seem like
something is being assigned incorrectly
it's a long process
but luckily since we do have a team that
does that before it reaches me
i can at least use it in the terms that
i know that merchants are happy with it
so
do you have do you have any as a
follow-up
do you have any
scope into like
roi for those purchases like is that
something that you guys have to deliver
on like
we bought all this external data here's
what we did with it and here's why it
was worth it oh for sure yeah um that's
that's been an ongoing conversation
the moment i said the word shiny app
so
because whenever what happened first is
uh there's a there's a guy named peter
cross um he's left walmart but he was
great he stood up our entire
infrastructure for art studio within
walmart and luckily enough i got to
piggyback on that even though i wasn't
on his team um so he gave me a license i
got to deploy some of my work start
doing some testing and as a poc
put rest of market out there
um and then whenever it was announced
that peter was leaving you know our
studio was uh kind of like falling by
the wayside for any of the team so we
picked it up the moment i said i needed
to pick it up for funding was the moment
we needed to do roi analysis and figure
out what it was actually going to do and
even at that time that was only when we
used one data set for e-commerce um so
yeah i wanted to make sure that
people knew that there's impact there
and so every i think about every three
months now we bring all the merchants
that have had success stories and they
demo their success stories for the other
merchants
so this will go out to the vps of their
leadership there's thousands of people
on the call
or at least thousands involved we see
who shows up
but the the merchants will get
information from other merchants that
makes them trust the source more
um and maybe dig into their e-commerce
space a little bit more
but my next release will be a lot larger
so
um we're thinking as we add things on we
want to keep showing them what the
benefit is
it's a little bit hard to track
perfectly in numbers because there's a
lot going on like it's not it's not even
just about the business impact it's
really that we're also doing all these
standardization and modeling practices
that were never there in the first place
um it's so it's it's valuing each piece
of that so
that's awesome thank you so much for
that no problem
brittany i know you had a similar
question so i
wanted to see if you had anything else
you want to add to that too
you know i think that's a a good point i
guess maybe
something else to add there is um
because you have another team that does
a lot of that data procurement
do you ever work cross-functionally with
them to like help them in learning what
kinds of data sets you need what like
specifically you're using it for and
sort of helping them and making sure
that they're procuring the right types
of data
yes yes um so they actually their use
case originally was market share data so
they wanted to understand
walmart versus amazon what's the market
share just in general and then be able
to break it out by
our divisions and then break it out by
department and so they're actually
starting at top level acquire as much
data as possible modularly model it out
make sure financially it's something
that can they can give to leadership for
for true insights and then they just
keep breaking down i started the
opposite way i started with all those
same data sets but at the item level
because for an assortment we predict out
to the certain departments uh roll up
and then eventually we're working on
meshing all of our stuff together so it
should be a full up and down roll up
through everything walmart
um so it's we're making sure that one
our modeling stuff stays in place
correctly because if we predict items in
one area and they're saying it goes to a
whole different area
we're not going to show the same numbers
so a lot of that does go on
it's like it's more like a monthly
cadence uh but we make sure that we're
aligned
awesome when you were talking about like
going through that process of showing
the roi of some of the shiny apps
i'd love to
like hear how you go through that
process because sometimes that
like i find it hard to take the time to
step back away from like your everyday
work to say
like hey this is
the roi of all of my projects
yeah
how do i say that so the
it for me it's a little bit easier just
to sit down with my boss since he's been
in the business a lot longer than i have
and he understands where things are
going to fit eventually
so when rest market came to me i assumed
that it was just a poc we're putting
dashboard up one data set
we've never had e-commerce sales shown
to somebody be done with it um but he
understands the next six or seven steps
that could happen uh so i'll normally
just get on a call with him
um ask him you know vague topic what i'm
thinking maybe give him two or three
bullet points and we go through and edit
list out everything that we can always
find either
data process data engineering insights
or
value-wise
for the merchant
and then after that
we it's just like a one-time thing we
don't we don't consistently update it it
really is ad hoc at this point um but
we're trying to get to more of a
framework for analyzing that later on so
i know i've asked you i've asked some
people on linkedin that was a linkedin
post to everybody by the way i think i
sent it to the our statistical
linkedin group um but yeah it's it's
pretty difficult whenever you don't know
exactly what all has been launched
either from a merchant uh just because
our systems aren't perfectly tied
so
yeah that's that's a great point it just
reminded me of that linkedin post too
and
um maybe that'd be something good to
open up to
the audience here too but i know that
post was around like
how do you show the value of shiny over
business intelligence tools as well when
your team is already
paying for multiple things um
so yeah i'd love to
hear like what you learned through that
but also open it up to other people who
have
maybe
had to have a similar conversation
uh yeah at least yes if anybody has
anything step in but at least in my
experience with the bi tool a
conversation um we've at least made our
our point
on maybe eight to ten things about why
we would have to pick shiny over a
different bi tool
um the first one really is just that we
have a lot of people on our team that
use r
so skill sets there
that's a pretty good use case the second
one is just that
drag and drop is pretty hard to document
um steps between each other
so something breaks and somebody else
needs to fix your visualization you
can't just read through some gg plot
steps or plotly or whatever it may be
and recreate it
you're typically googling in a forum
somewhere and then hoping that somebody
put a screenshot of every button they
clicked
so
um or a video or something so it's
that's that's a little bit more
difficult and then number three our
scale uh most data models especially
like power bi data models don't
typically handle water scale
um i know there's some data warehouse
and data mart stuff that they're doing
recently haven't checked it out yet uh
tableau
you know big it can connect to bigquery
or something which is cool
but the processing and then tablet data
extracts are just it's just not enough
uh for the amount of assortment we deal
with so
um i mean when we think about historical
assortment of walmart it's 250 million
today
for if you need two years of analysis
you know by day and that's just for the
items you haven't joined in performance
metrics yet so um
typically we have to deal it with
staging batch analysis put inside a big
query expose it and shiny and then go
forward
cool thank you
if other people have thoughts too or
things to share feel free to raise your
hand here
yes what's up just a little bit of data
yeah millions and millions
i guess uh
there's no question um what are i mean
this was great in terms of understanding
a lot of the like process of like how
walmart works but what are the things
i guess that um
you guys are looking towards in the
future to kind of that excites you um
both both technically or
otherwise
yeah so the um i think the social
listening piece is going to be really
cool um i'd like to i'd like to get into
more data sources so one thing that
we've learned is that you know google
search and google trends are normally a
a like pre-indicator of sales inside of
the market um it's it's a really good
lead signal um and so the first thing
that we've done is like at a brand level
um you can drill in from our app into
google trends and so
you can click up to five trends that's
their limitation but it allows you to
find a lot of the search results that
are trending in the market the geography
of that and then what the top results
are over time as well as like you know
check brands just against each other
um and so that's that was impactful
already enough for a merchant because
they could see oh timberland's trending
up what's going on and there's some
collaboration of timberland and
some designer uh and then maybe they
want to try to get in on marketing on
that or whatever it may be
and so that was that was cool enough
much less getting into like uh tick tock
uh like to know it
um all these different apps that
nobody's really like we've never sourced
it at walmart before
or if we have it's for specific one-off
things that we may do in marketing and
so now this is this is really our group
tie-ins marketing um and i don't know
that's that's
we're here kind of siloed we're giving
everybody cool stuff but i want to be
with catalog marketing data science data
engineering and then push it all back
out
um so that our systems can utilize a
little bit more i think that's that's
probably the biggest excitement at
walmart right now
that's amazing
um i see there's a question on slide oh
too that was how are you able to connect
the shiny apps in r with your internal
database information systems
yeah yeah so i uh i just use odbc
drivers through rstudio they have
professional drivers for bigquery
they don't have one i think for presto
which is where we have a lot of our
layers kind of thrown out there from gcp
um so we we have our own presto
connector that we use i think there's
the r presto uh shiny power r package
that you can use for connecting but most
of it's odbc we used to use jdbc but we
recently converted over
and then i'll use like the database like
pool package to make sure that
connections stay on and revolving
through bigquery because there is time
out stuff um but yeah i'll just connect
through bigquery and that i'll use
dbplier uh either inside of the back end
of shiny or for development of a sql
query um just to get a flow down and
then me and my co-worker usually work
together if we need to use python's api
to optimize it
great um
i was just curious so
i know this is a tool that you provide
to
the merchants as well so
is this something that's like greatly
improved their experience of working
with walmart or i'm just trying to like
put myself in the shoes of who's using
the shiny up honestly i think i think at
this point
it doesn't help them process wise
like that's that's the whole point about
connecting to these systems is to
actually improve their processes with
the data now now that we actually know
what they need and what what insights
they're going for and where else we can
build
right now it's it's honestly probably
more work
because they they come to our app they
find insights and then they've got to
actually execute and do something to it
and in the e-commerce space that's
typically always at bulk unless we're
putting inside of something specific in
our fulfillment center
um so that it's
it's probably harder actually for them
right now because they they need to
drill in to understand what their gap is
um there's predictions to their category
so it could be incorrect so they're
giving us feedback
um we have items mapped to it that are
anywhere from 90 to 100
similar but that doesn't mean it's
always right could be a short item
description or something and so we could
be giving them a little bit of false
information they have to sift through
um so yeah i mean it's it's four to five
maybe six more steps than they're
actually used to for the e-commerce
space
but it's data they've never had before
ever
and so it kind of outweighs it currently
but that's why we really need to push to
getting this this data inside of item
catalog so that when they come in shiny
give
we can recommend hey give us two things
and we can set up the top item in your
market with the supplier and that's it
instead of oh
here you found your item go to this tool
set it up in the item process go to this
tool add the supplier to our area go to
this tool order some inventory for it
now it's it's becoming a little bit
mundane so
thank you
i know we have people on the data
science hangout from so many different
like sizes of companies and different
industries
and i was just curious like what's the
biggest challenge that you've
faced working at
a company as large as walmart and
and how do you overcome that
uh there's a lot um so
the size of the scale of our
organization just in merchandising means
that you can't even send a total
merchandising uh communication email
so you need to get the word out it's not
through that what else are you gonna use
um so it's it comes down to a lot of
word of mouth it comes down to a lot of
trust coming from the merchants
even if you send out a mass
communication email you could be in the
wrong quarter of planning for them to
even look at your e-commerce space so
they don't care at that point and then
they forget about it and then you need
to send something else out again
um so a lot of it does come down to like
we'll do departmental strategies so
we'll go hey we've got 55 departments uh
it's a lot of meetings but if we can
group some of them together we can make
it 20 and then we'll do maybe an hour
hour and a half demo of how you'd
actually use the tool what's coming up
next and then the feedback session uh
just some type of deep dive with them
and then every quarter like i said there
there's the monthly
demo from the merchant side
that's the that's the larger format one
where they where all departments are
invited to come they're not forced to
come
uh but yeah it's just calendar
management
um being able to say no to certain tasks
because you're gonna have 300 people ask
you about something because you're a sme
um
and then communications
and communications is always always the
the hardest part
um especially if somebody gets a hold of
your data asset and starts making uh
somewhat the same tool as you
so then you have to fight for merchants
using one tool or the other so
thank you that's really helpful
um a follow-up question that came
through about that is how do you decide
what to say no to
uh business prioritization uh so since i
work on the business side i don't really
operate like tech it's not um like we
kind of prioritize prioritize our own
impacts based on
current versus long-term strategy like
if we
if we just decided that
we were going to move
inventory from all of our fulfillment
centers to the store for some reason
then we would need to focus on that
first the business impact is there if we
feel like we don't have the bandwidth
right now
we have to turn it down and try to see
if somebody else can support it
otherwise if we think that it trumps
something that we're currently doing
we'll put one or two people on it kick
it out real fast as fast as possible and
then go back to focusing on something
else
but it always just comes down to like
what we think is the most important at
that time which is a very generic answer
you've got like
um
i don't know it's not even based on
dollar impact it's maybe you have a data
asset that you think is going to be more
valuable in the long term you've got to
work on it now
because in next month if you don't have
it by next month it's going to be a year
before the merchants even come back to
it again
so it's it really does come down to like
timeline planning
especially at the store side
thank you
alexander so you just put a question
into the chat you want to jump in
um yeah sure um i don't have my camera
hi everybody i'm alex um i just wanted
to ask you know all these apps you
create seem really great and like
honestly it seems like a lot of work too
um so i'm on a pretty small team of data
scientists or kind of aspiring data
scientists that would call us
a lot of us have more of a research
background and we're kind of starting to
do a little bit more collaborative
coding
um but i have found that process to be
pretty challenging even with github so
i'm curious if if you if a lot of this
work you're doing are you working with a
team of people on programming and if so
how do you kind of manage
the different pieces of putting together
um these applications
yeah yeah so the the first app i've ever
built at walmart was actually in the tax
group um and it was full lone wolf there
was no one else on that project i talked
to somebody else on the business side
about the current access database that
they were using just so i could port it
all over and just strip it from the
ground up
so that was that was full lone wolf um i
love building it just because i like the
whole process of every part of data uh
didn't now we're working more
collaboratively so actually i had uh the
privilege of uh getting my
uh old classmate hired onto our team
directly uh me and him just worked side
by side we both did our masters we both
built our first shiny app together in
our master's program um and so he's a
lot more back in focus
uh he's a lot better at optimization um
i'm a lot better at i guess like design
ux and reactivity and shot inside of
shiny
as well as like a little bit more like
the business side and so
we just try to divvy up things that we
feel like um we can split out like i'll
build one shiny module and then he'll
work on the back end and then by the
time he's done with the back end i can
pull the table in modify just the things
that i need instead of shiny and then
that's the full process um we don't do a
lot of collaborative things where like
he's going into my module specifically
while i'm working on it uh and then you
have to deal with the github like merge
and make sure everything actually lines
up
um so we try to dedicate this page is
mine i'm just gonna i'm gonna do that
you can give me insights on this page
but i'm gonna just own this one and then
that's always gonna be my module and
then we'll document all of the
responsibilities of the data flow inside
of we use confluence
and then from there we just always know
who's working and owning what
well that's great i really like how you
bring up the point of like identifying
each other's strengths
um
and um using that to kind of prioritize
who can help with what so thanks that's
actually really helpful feedback
yeah i will say on the data science side
um we used to have a merchant data
science group specific to merchandising
that is now upstream and they're no
longer like a pillar they're horizontal
across all of tech technically
um but working with them
was also a different thing like they did
also handle most of the
they handle all the modeling
some of the data engineering process
but in the end all i really need was
their stage table
so um they give me they give me a stage
table i put inside the shiny app i
collect feedback for their predictions i
send it back to another stage table for
them so they can retrain on inside of
bigquery
and then once again we keep most of our
stuff separated
i have some testing scripts to make sure
that whenever their final output is
overwritten or they append to it that
all the stuff actually checks uh so that
i don't have to look at it but that's
that's really all it is is testing other
people's stuff if you don't own it and
then also testing your own stuff and
making sure you own it so
thank you
thank you um javier i see you asked a
question too if you want to ask live
sure thanks and alec hey nice to finally
put a face to a name
hey man
yeah alec and i have had like a
linkedin
our shiny specific relationship the last
few years
so anyway um
the
[Music]
you know i i know you know this but uh
most of my
career was in financial modeling and so
in financial
reporting um the last few years being
more specific in data science i haven't
really been working for finance
you know as a function although i team
with them often
i guess my question to you is i've
noticed a trend where as
more
and more viewers get access to an app
there seems to be more and more appetite
for
finance wanting metrics to align to the
official record or the official reports
and it's like
i i understand why that is important um
but
for certain operations or sales teams
you know they're wanting to kind of
splice and dice the data in a way that
may not reconcile 100 to finance
i'm just curious if you've like run into
this and maybe how you've pushed back or
kind of gotten around this kind of you
know
hurdle i guess
uh we got lucky um so
walmart organically has decided that
finance and merchandising will have
different reporting structures so
finance has its own hierarchy for
reporting uh its sales and figures and
then merchandising has its own hierarchy
and so we got we got really lucky for
that but
the way that we kind of that use case
came about was that
um on the finance side
they actually have to attribute
uh we sell things on the app
from the store
so it's e-comm based but store fulfilled
finance has to say everything is for
coming from the store you credit the
store for it
merchandising we want to show that oh
well our assortment was actually app
initiated through the customer we're
customer based not finance based so all
of our reporting goes somewhere else and
then we actually we have different uh
channel reporting so we we don't even
report the same types of channels that
they do
um we we finally got like fully
separated from that
in the end that question still does come
up like finance is going to come back
and say hey
we see that you're reporting a market
share
you know we're we're trying to report on
true market share how does this uh kind
of differ
well when i report on market share it's
based on 29 retailers i don't i have
sample based retailer knowledge these
are insights we're predicting they won't
ever tie out
and we just have to put forward that use
case up front so that
if they do ever come with more questions
they already know
the issue that you know obviously is
that like on our side finances also
thousands of people
and so how do you know how do you make
finance know about all of that and so
i've i've been trying to create
more
in-app documentation as to what the
scope of the app is going to be
now and forever
kind of like an faq or something
yeah
so i uh
bs4 dash is making that pretty easy now
since there's the extra nav bar
uh the secondary sidebar that you can
like the right sidebar or i think it has
a new name now yeah yeah the control bar
control bar yeah control bar comes out
there's a learning hub pill and i do a
purpose
um a video like full end to end video of
using the application and then the scope
and stuff there frequently asked
questions whatever else you can do
um and then if anybody ever needs
anything go there learn it you can come
ask me afterwards but i'm just i'm gonna
point them there first if they haven't
looked at it
so
thank you that helps yeah
thank you
i see parth asked in the chat what are
the best techniques that optimize the
shiny app while dealing with this huge
amount of data
uh so once again i'm lucky uh because of
our studio connect so we have a massive
server behind it with
high availability and auto scaling
so that that typically takes care of
concurrency for the most part
database pool also keeps connections
alive for everybody to have pretty
seamless experience of connections
coming on and off which doesn't overload
our gcp project
our queries we we since we stage a lot
of our data up front that we do need um
we make sure it's super targeted
everything's uh star schema if we can
make it otherwise it's filtered specific
to a merchant's hierarchy so queries are
really quick
uh i think the longest query that we
actually have running in a production
app today it takes eight to nine seconds
um and so we don't deal with query
concurrency too terribly
most the time whenever people are making
that nine second query it's going to
pull them back hundreds of thousands of
items um so they're going to be looking
at that view for a long time they're not
going to be going to another thing
i think it depends on your use case so
one issue we've seen is if you need to
make
like large input sheet submissions so
what we like to do is uh there's our
hands-on table package
if we require like 20 inputs or
something for for whatever reason it's
really easy to just record them there
uh but if you got three thousand
merchants doing a different different
type of query where it's actually
submitting back to the database rather
than pulling uh that's a different
that's it's totally different you have
to handle it differently um and so there
has been some challenges with that i'm
still working around what the best
practices for that i use bq upload a bq
upload from the bigger query package for
a really fast upload into our table
and then we just try to make sure we
partition and cluster anything possible
uh just to make all of our tables run
really fast so
um it's it's a lot of thought it's a lot
of design and up front like
hey what can we do to reduce this data
scale because it's never going to fit in
the app if we don't
uh but eventually we get it small enough
that our our stuff's targeted so
okay i've been trying to find the
packages and put them in the chat as you
mentioned them but i couldn't find that
eq upload one oh it's it's just
from hadley's yes from hadley's bigger
query package
okay
um
so on
the topic of finance i know you have a
previous background in accounting and
i'm curious how
that has helped in your role in your
analytics role now
um i think the accounting principles
don't really help me at all anymore it's
more of the fact of like whenever i was
digging for accounting and tax data in
the tax department it exposed me to
all of walmart so if i was an audit
we get audited on everything and every
state auditor every local auditor wants
to edit our audit walmart because if you
can even get one percent of that audit
as an error
you're gonna get a lot of money from us
um and so
we would be digging i'll just dig and
dig and dig and dig all the time uh
through audit principles that way uh
learned all of the tables and then
whenever i came over to merchandising it
was super easy i'd already been exposed
to most the tables that we would use in
the first place for sales
profits uh any type of item availability
discounts are a big one
exempt purchases so i knew how to pull
those out
up front and that makes my analysis
cleaner so just understanding like what
you would and wouldn't record
through sales or
whatever industry may be
it just makes a lot of my analysis
cleaner up front
so i don't have to ask merchants later
on
if the data's right and then them tell
me i didn't deduct discounts so
i typically think about a lot of those
concepts beforehand
awesome
and just a reminder if anyone wants to
ask a question live do you feel free to
just raise your hand on zoom as well
let's see do we have any other questions
over on slido
um i'm
i can ask questions
and i'm curious are there people that
have started to want to
like learn data science now that they've
seen some of the
apps that you've created
yeah we're actually putting together a
different work stream for a psc where
we're trying to actually we're trying to
get an intern to do most of the
templating of the shiny app up front
now that we do have a pretty good
structure for bs4 dash it's really
simple just to give them a couple of
things she has she has experience in r
before and this just gives her another
10 to 13 weeks during her internship to
learn more
i think it's really cool once you
already have an app like rom out there
where there's true business impact and
showing what it can do
people are excited and they want to get
into it anyways
so like i said on our team we do have a
lot of our skills and we've grown that a
little bit organically through our
hiring
so we've got five to six people that are
willing to jump in and do our maybe not
shiny right now but getting into
markdown and from mark down you get into
flex dashboard and then flex dashboard
you get into shiny so
there's there's kind of a road map into
getting into that and in the meantime
they're still building out pipelines and
uh data skills that they need for shiny
um
there's there's been different groups
wanting to get on our connect server for
deployment
so that's cool
plus uh the tax still is maintaining uh
some of my apps from a couple of years
ago
that i'd given them so it kind of forces
them to be inside of our shining so
we've that gives exposure to some of our
development teams since they're
maintaining it in a central source uh
and even them they've enjoyed actually
tweaking old apps and stuff that i've
had
so it's it's just exposure all around to
different different groups
awesome and
i mean in such a big company too
how do you let people know like what's
possible like oh that you could use this
r studio instance like do you have a
a group like a team's channel or
something
yeah we've got a we've got a team's
channel it's really only for people that
have the licenses right now
but most of it does come through demos
and uh what i like to do now is i'll
show rom and then show them the business
case and be like hey this is what i've
built today but
here's bs4 dash there's like a there's a
showcase example or something that the
guy has a live shiny app up on and you
can click through all the components
it's literally just like a testing
module of everything in bs4 dash i'm
like hey
this is what we have today and then
here's everything available that i've
not even touched yet that we could do
with any other shiny app so like social
boxes or timelines or
stuff that i haven't even incorporated
and so that it gives a lot of people um
like a spinning wheel in their creative
space and they think about the problems
that they have and go oh wow like
visually i now understand how i could
tie something together like that it is
possible i've seen it technically be
done
uh thank you javier that's that's the
perfect if you want to run that function
you can actually see what i'm talking
about uh and then if they're like hey i
want that he's got the github out there
i control f i search for whatever
component it is and it's now going to go
in my shiny app so
um it's it's pretty easy just to walk
people through
here's what we've done and actually has
worked here's something we could do and
then people just start throwing out
ideas for you to work on
that's great and those demos that's just
with different teams across the business
uh yeah it depends on who it is um like
if it's
if it's on our side which is like
merchant operations and innovation uh
that'll be more for maybe design teams
or central platforms that my work will
eventually go into
or um if it's
something that i need to do it's
features that people are requesting from
the merchant side that hey is this
available is this possible i can show
them one way it's possible do you like
that yes or no if they say yes then i
can start working on it if not
i'll just start exploring and see if i
can find another example and show it to
them um but i try to make sure i always
give them some type of visual along with
some fake data upfront because people
like to change their minds once they see
data involved
so yeah
um i'm i'm curious for people listening
in it is walmart hiring now or do you
have any open analytics roles yeah
there's uh i i know that we're gonna be
hiring uh soon on our team for a
role i believe it's the same level as me
there'll be a senior manager to roll
but i think it's specific to apparel
innovation i'm not sure exactly what
it'd be but it'd be it'd be really
product based uh maybe even more central
application central platform based i
don't know what the requirement is on
that yet but all across walmart we're
hiring i think there's currently like 40
000 job listings out there for all over
the country
and we're getting a lot better about
remote work uh so we're finally actually
saying hey we're not even worried about
the hubs now as long as you're close to
a hub
fine and hub being like
uh san bruno california dallas texas
benville arkansas
uh hoboken new jersey
new york
and i forget where else it is but uh
we're saying like as long as you're
within a certain like nothing's like
300 or something miles that would be
okay with you so that you can always go
into a hub if needed um just fly in or
whatever um but yeah there's there's a
lot of things that are out there it's
hard for me to comment on just because
there's so much but if you have a
jawbreak
you can send it to me on linkedin
i can actually see who the hiring
manager is and see like what type of
organization it'd be for
and i can try to help people if y'all if
y'all find something you're looking for
that's great and i'll share your
linkedin
in the chat there too um but zach i see
you had a question do you want to jump
in
yeah sure uh
hey elk um
i i know that we had
actually talked about this like a while
ago um but
uh we talked about like production
applications and
the split between basically like
software engineering and data science
and i was curious if you could just
expand on that
like what does that split look like
today are you learning anything fun uh
interesting
yeah yeah so the so
in my case i guess it depends on when
you draw the line for production so like
the the audit tracker that's inside of
tax it's been up for two and a half
years now and i'd almost call it
production at this point even though
it's supposed to just be an mvp
my work i still call an mvp uh for the
shiny application because as i give the
business what it needs right now we push
stuff up into the systems and then
eventually once the systems are ready
that's when we'll actually bring the
full um central platform with rest of
market ported into it and so i'll give a
lot of my learnings over at that point
and that's when we'll go into like true
software engineering and production
systems uh but in the meantime
they're building other stuff i'm
building something that nests
gives people what they need um and
they'll do a transfer later on
what is the i guess like the
collaboration model look like um so how
do you
how do you essentially like transfer
whatever you built to
basically someone that's going to recode
it
uh yeah so the it depends on like how
big the project is like an analysis
i did something called unproductive skus
so where we're just checking at an item
level if something's productive or not
and with that it was as simple as just
sharing a sql query giving them some
sources some understanding as to why the
logic's there
and then showing them from a ui side how
they can actually make it flexible and
that was it the rest of markets can be a
whole different beast because there's so
many components to it
but i'm really just going to show them
the flow that we're going for what
merchants like and don't like because
i'll have a ton of feedback from
merchants about hey maybe they hate the
app right now
and then i can give those learnings over
as
ui ux design workflow uh data sources
and then hopefully just be able to point
them to source systems to build their
stuff out and so by the time we get
there that's really all it should be
they shouldn't even really need much of
my sql at that point
that's true thanks nice seeing you okay
nice to see you too dude
thanks alec i i know we're right at the
top of the art but just a quick question
when you say mvp is that minimum viable
okay my head always goes like most
valuable player there
well thank you all so much for joining
and thank you so much alex for sharing
your experience and
getting to learn from you and
i love being able to hear all your shiny
stories on linkedin too
i shared your i shared your linkedin in
the chat too so if anybody wants to
connect or has follow-up questions too
sweet thanks everybody thanks for the
time
thanks all have a great day bye
you